ozark is driving toward a thrilling
conclusion and ruth is heading to war
with marty bird netflix's ozark has long
been known for its willingness to push
the envelope when it comes to depictions
of loss and tragedy while many
characters on the series are familiar
with these unfortunate aspects of life
you have as much experience with them as
ruth langmore in fact the sadness at the
center of ruth's life begins long before
audiences meet her at the beginning of
the series
as a young girl ruth loses her mother to
a drunk driver and her only sources of
direction in life become her criminal
uncles and toxic father more on them
later it seems safe to say that marty
bird is the first genuine father figure
in ruth's life the marty's introduction
into ruth's life initially offers her a
path beyond a life of dead and poverty
his presence also repeatedly costs root
the people she loves most season one
sees ruth forced to kill her own uncles
to save marty while season two shows
wendy bird quietly arranged the death of
ruth's father kade season 3 takes things
to an all-new low and wendy allows the
cartel to kill her mentally ill brother
ben who also happens to be ruth's
boyfriend time and time again marty's
operation always seems to target those
closest to her after so much tragedy it
really shouldn't come as much of a shock
but eventually marty's business cost
ruth more than she could ever possibly
have imagined at the end of ozark season
4 seventh episode sanctified avi
alexandro decides to have his revenge on
darlene immediately after darlene's
wedding to wyatt javi surprises the
improbably happy couple in their home
and shoots him pulled dead leaving their
bodies for ruth to find while we don't
actually see or hear ruth's reaction to
the grisly discovery it's safe to say
she is immediately distraught at the
sudden loss of her favorite cousin after
37 episodes of near continuous
heartbreak for ruth wyatt's death simply
seems like one loss too many for ruth to
take for years ruth encouraged wyatt to
seek a life better than the one she
feels destined to live more than
anything she wants to see why it break
the langmore curse and escape the ozarks
once and for all sadly with a single
gunshot javi robs wyatt of his future
and ruth of any potential vicarious
happiness as she pulls out of the former
snell langmore driveway ruth drives
erratically clearly emotional over the
discovery after her original assumption
that frank cosgrove jr is to blame has
quickly proven incorrect a far more
devastating truth is revealed in spite
of all the two have done for each other
and the trust they have been probably
built marty continues to have a toxic
effect on her life in the aftermath of
her sudden realization of the real
culprits ruth returns to the birdhouse
and threatens to kill marty if he
doesn't tell her who is directly
responsible for why it's death though
jonah is quick to give up hobbies names
such knowledge seems like it will do
little to stop a coming war between ruth
and the rest of the bird family the bird
family's entire future relies on hobby's
continued breathing something ruth is
clearly unwilling to accept
though crude outbursts and high strong
emotions are somewhat typical of ruth
this encounter seems different to a
significant extent this time she really
means it
if you want to stop me you're going to
have to
kill me
the langmores and the birds have
quarreled for years resulting in a
number of deaths but the loss of wyatt
is unique with each prior loss ruth
finds a way to rationalize marty's
involvement when her uncles die ruth is
willing to set up their execution
herself when her father dies even ruth
has to admit that he was not a good
person and while ben's death was
certainly the most difficult for her to
accept ruth always seems to blame wendy
more than marty in this case there is no
separating marty's involvement with a
cartel from wyatt's death and javi's
continued protection worse yet ruth now
has nothing left to lose
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]